oh there's a snake inside a snake inside
a snake inside a snake hey my name's Ann
Jones and I'm the abcs resident nature
nerd and today we're talking about no
Proops
[Music]
alright let's get started snick snick
snick I hope no one's watching this over
breakfast
oh wow oh wow okay a couple amuse a big
bird oh wow look at that wrapping it
wrapping up that's incredible
look at it holding on by just the end of
its tail
you can see how rigid those muscles are
so pythons will often be up in trees and
often you'll be underneath or very close
to a Python without ever realizing it
because they are very very camouflage Oh
what okay we've got a bit of cannibalism
happening oh well so there's two snakes
even though it might look like one funny
one the Eastern brown snake is actually
eating a Python in this it's actually a
pretty smart thing to do if you think
about it from a snake perspective
another snake is actually the same shape
as your stomach so as you go and suck it
in you know you've got something that's
stretched out right along your digestive
area mmm well okay we've got a Python
constricting hair so this is a great
example of the constricting behavior of
pythons how they kill isn't with venom
but it's by crushing their victim and
there's this idea that pythons actually
suffocate their prey and that's not
actually the case some recent research
has shown that they constricts around
and actually stop the blood flow and
from there the heart stops and from
there the breathing stops what oh no my
word so we've got a carpet python who is
eating some sort of macro pod a little
wallaby type thing and oh it's really
going for it it's really interesting
because the the body of the snake is all
sort of curled up and tense and its
really working like basically every part
of a snake's body as you go along is all
all right and it's just working every
single one of them let's let's let's go
to the next one because I'm feeling sick
hmm
sort of looks like water ripples in one
way my first reaction on seeing that was
hey it's like sexy snake time but their
heads are up and that's an aggressive
position so I think that these are males
having a fight and they go from sort of
on someone's verandah to outside it can
happen over a really long period of time
like hours they can fight for days even
to see who will be dominant and to be
the winner you've got to hold your
opponent down on the ground into sort of
you know I suppose submission and when
you lose you just go off into the
distance and the other guy gets to go
make love seeing a snake in your
backyard doesn't necessarily mean that
that snake is an immediate danger to you
I understand that they're sort of freaky
I mean I get freaked out too but they
will move on of their own accord
especially if they don't find food or
shelter in the local area that is
terrifying
in that very first photo you can sort of
see a crocodile leg lean limply okay
that's terrifying these photos show so
well that jaw really stretching out to
take in a whole crocodile that can't be
cool so there's this myth around that
snakes actually dislocate their jaws in
order to take in the prey hole and
that's not what happens they've actually
got this stretchy ligament that
stretches out and then moves back into
place and it's all completely natural
though it does look a little
uncomfortable snakes do not seem to be
intimidated by super sized meals there
are snakes in Australia that are
incredibly dangerous to humans but the
majority really for all intents and
purposes they're just like Boosh tinsel
decorating
face
all right so if you've got a video that
you've taken of Australian nature out
there and you want us to have a look at
it and see what we can see why don't you
subscribe and leave us a link to the
video in the comments and we'll make
sure that we'll get to it soon